Eh,
Impresario,
the
outdoor,
they
don't,
they know that Kim fake lavish,
Eh,
the
elution
David
[inaudible] the [inaudible].
Well,
no,
but I
expect though in in sale or their personas persona.
Ms. Dot.
Rathee to libido this is,
is
killing all of the mass.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] Pando me.
Nope.
The last personas,
personas.
Lo Mas Importante
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] a Las personas.
Better Como [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] I will say,
I will share the persona.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] he made them,
we'd be libido.
He made them women in northeast [inaudible] Paradise Mooncup Innovation
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] astrophysical muscling.
Think astrophysical after physical cables.
Gun permit to [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] go Caples or networking [inaudible]
he's implemented
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] e e e [inaudible] Laquinya Laquinya Caminos.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] Las personas
and
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] and
[inaudible] [inaudible] but it's applicant networking.
[inaudible] Nada,
Nada.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] must make the meal photos and selfies.
No,
no,
no.
She didn't get a
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] okay.
This one's a bit,
okay.
This is
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] a [inaudible] a [inaudible] first eh e [inaudible].
Hello?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] persona c
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] a
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] that's purple.
Paolo
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] needs money.
No,
it's rarely that.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] he left the Saunas.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] into the loss campos in fill those and had been in that.
They don't think move forces,
but they're not getting up as you're not getting it.
Okay.
Or make me leave it as well.
So
we
went up.
Amia
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] eh?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] 90 meters.
No.
Is he still loves stimulus is he still loves bowels.
Bowels show he's vow or she in Portola Persona c
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] obviously
being boy wonder then he knows he studies in a
[inaudible] [inaudible] or [inaudible] 54 the intro.
What's the purpose?
You look at studies.
Look at studies this year.
Nursing
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] Los Alamitos.
[inaudible]
no,
I knew Nina
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] a few minutes.
Okay.
I will.
I know.
Buco comparison
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] eh,
eh,
Arabic [inaudible] e
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] you will immediately go and see
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] not focusing on no.
Looked at it the most or
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] billion something together for
the better.
Simply the money in a positive [inaudible] persona.
The Manila see near though.
See me though?
Ruthenium Munici near though.
In real school.
No Standard Latinos here in Rico is tampered there.
Is this a real school?
Is this from the partner?
Is part of it.
Tell us personas
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] personas.
I think one reason [inaudible] what do you get?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] nothing in responding.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] told us,
told us he raised I Lutheran or local tomato.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
of the [inaudible] is fantastic.
Look,
his face,
the,
there was trust Casa,
so there's wasn't the lobby ice Deangelo police Arthur.
Lot of ways that their case [inaudible] perfect.
[inaudible] dot.
[inaudible] told me being,
being sad in [inaudible].
Coach always say nothing.
So,
or why is [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] if not
personas.
So nobody,
not any job or that being for Santa Claus.
[inaudible] [inaudible] was promoted in Canada on momentum.
It was sad and try new Momento and what can I pick a few and like again,
ice in [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] hello Kate Talis task.
And it's a persona.
No problem.
They must own the Kiddo ohm.
Ohm Mayor Lego [inaudible] after Lou Barkasy porky Aussie importa pork Yassine
Porta [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] small business,
no Palestine.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] personas are federal
law are law or cause he knows per these lavita surveys,
but at the end of massive of Barbados,
our office space to get one the stays manitos or [inaudible] hospital was
pervasive total per cables to move.
He knows by
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] is a persona.
It's just important.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
as
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] he cannot come.
[inaudible]
that's great.
Yeah.
This is brand new.
Let's get that woman in.
Methods to military
[inaudible]
yes.
Or no matter what you use to kill us.
Coaches a
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] fun solo song.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] consignors hyper [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] pay?
No.
Okay.
No,
I mean
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
and if there's a [inaudible] persona,
he,
but I think I noticed those [inaudible]
[inaudible] demos cost
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] hmm.
[inaudible] C'mon gathers too.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] per month.
Yeah.
Hold on,
hold on.
Yes.
No.
[inaudible] no one knows the [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] Costa TV.
[inaudible] on pack.
If Thomas is,
this is the music,
is the mark [inaudible] all they're married?
No,
no,
no.
It's the totals.
Showrunners are Mercosur personas.
Yeah.
Those consortia,
Khan,
and who run at American [inaudible] Todos Talos it 10 minimum south caucus three
stereotype or not [inaudible] so how are they married to typical more to talk in
parochial,
momentous feminist that you need to go,
he has no mass.
60 mosquitoes has capacities.
All of his persona.
He was [inaudible] personas.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] or either,
yeah,
it must in system [inaudible] so
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] coach named
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] we are [inaudible].
I kept [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] possibility the other.
Then the interview Carol,
our lows.
Alice.
Alice opinionative was Tara [inaudible].
She'll be really manager should be done in an idea.
[inaudible]
you should have said they've asked us confront your cannabis in preparing me up
in there.
[inaudible] we got Mencken Tao
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] they see it's taken part in the
clique.
Look at Bbdo.
Locate people.
The area,
mentee,
Loki,
Pico,
the area mentee
[inaudible] [inaudible] party.
Second Party continual compared to the commercial are comparatively low mean
[inaudible] persona kilo practical.
Been more [inaudible] eh,
eh.
[inaudible] Park is tough.
Intolerant.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
this is her.
Look at you.
You looked animals.
Okay.
Pick up the tenemos que money.
Fermosa
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] is this look is,
is it [inaudible]?
Is that Lucas
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] he knows his team.
Idos la [inaudible] is [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] Super Juanito but at an income or
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] passing courses
there.
Orpheus,
Eh,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] cities cannot in,
in Salida.
[inaudible]
and
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
but I do that Solo
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] can be mass mass.
Moscow saw say a [inaudible] they'll,
they'll,
they'll then talking about the,
the,
the therapy pizza being eh,
[inaudible] [inaudible] or
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] come up with,
oh,
[inaudible] we know IP solution.
Eunice
sidewalk in monuments arcade whenever say hello,
Pablo hunting personas.
Fantastic.
[inaudible] [inaudible] 19 the fuck any piece of centers are going to hit
[inaudible] and
[inaudible] [inaudible] boring ea Boosie
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] when a percent on track
[inaudible] [inaudible] being not persona [inaudible] Sam Antonio Lou being in
the Valencia Salaverry Maine.
They were worried it was when a lot of us,
they see me or anything,
so I haven't even read [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] cost [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] Kinda convinced that
their owners,
they see risk cost.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] a Fintech,
a [inaudible] pocket pocket.
Todos Tenemos is a possibility that total spinning was supposed to be there.
Look at [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] office.
There's only Milano Trattoria [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
how are we going to go to [inaudible]?
Amara?
How's your week pressing?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] dad visited the dark [inaudible] the [inaudible] was
that,
yes.
Come on.
They took eat
taco
Michael stole mine
was not nonmembers [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] got Fantastica
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] a [inaudible] Citi
[inaudible] guys,
what I'm thinking
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] are fairly low.
Arthur.
Not In air.
[inaudible] not an immediate threat of England.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] it's the important thing.
[inaudible]
know
[inaudible] [inaudible] you don't want a loan to know she didn't mean this time.
I,
I just blow a CD.
[inaudible] in La.
Oh,
I can
see
e
c c c c is read aloud
a
government.
They could,
yeah.
Plateau.
Cassie,
Cassie.
Oh,
Ho,
Ho.
Say Oh,
hold on.
I said
no,
I did not know somebody
without,
no,
no.
[inaudible] I plucked Catos yes.
I Carlos lost her.
Mario's Mario,
Mario Nebraska
studios.
You know,
you're sort of thing.
Go.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] I wrote
[inaudible] [inaudible] so it's a little somebody
switch.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] King Kini last
[inaudible] [inaudible] better Vilna,
not her phone.
Latinas to Kim has de [inaudible] and this keeping it a lot of fun,
but Killara phone
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] de Las personas and
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] more just with this makeup,
which is,
if you must say [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] and that mobility
[inaudible] [inaudible] as soon as from program for [inaudible] birthday,
vertical Latinas
in Lapland
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] from Dallas soc one do general pieces,
when are they given any Tunica media when the
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] or
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] totals to others,
but a saline,
they said [inaudible] faster.
The others,
it says
[inaudible] [inaudible] leadership.
We don't mind at the top and I don't know,
the guy made are ill,
porky,
the
14 [inaudible] on this.
This,
they will
buy it.
I won't get on and
he can do you know the hint the matter be Joseph [inaudible] phone [inaudible] I
have to start what holidays are coming out of Washington professional or us.
How'd you dot homages persona.
So [inaudible] to Kelly [inaudible] motto but Tuxedo,
Grandpa
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] I would run in theater,
no own in theater.
That is the
[inaudible] [inaudible] Joseph Nicolaus [inaudible] no
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] in theater row.
The end of the Fintech,
Kyla [inaudible],
SONA
and windows area.
Nicole equally ground swell to take your skills.
Could read Aptos.
They stopped in boisterous man.
Who's
[inaudible] [inaudible] no police fellow base.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
on the personas.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] it was no trouble chemos for Krista centers to political
customers still those being travel come up for La [inaudible] for that.
Oh,
because we impresario
and also in political,
although he saw you need to go to the political,
so the Impresario [inaudible] personas can me [inaudible] okay.
Cause this to the school.
So he does when he's [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] when he started with this New Yorker,
soon I'm Yada
empathy pocket [inaudible] the [inaudible] Aminos.
But if they cannot start the [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] he's still a Shinto,
but it is.
They cannot start in
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] came myspace.
Cantando [inaudible] see me.
He
was,
he what does have land in [inaudible]? [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
I wouldn't have known.
He said,
we'll look and see how they feel that
they've done.
They did on the,
Sally's think that is going to dinners,
public personas prometric [inaudible] the,
they've been saddle [inaudible] the Orient [inaudible] devalued car.
A joke.
Grill them the
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] no.
[inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] you cannot
[inaudible] [inaudible] think when Tanya's okay.
It's took him in the [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] ambulance personas [inaudible] may not [inaudible]
Pamela Personas [inaudible] tooth.
No looking it up.
Winter Escape Mip Posto Arcos three [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] no price to not famous total scholars memos.
[inaudible] no [inaudible] personas.
But if I'm in an [inaudible],
the telcos are the cost.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] a
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] lots and lots and lots of law school to
lethal.
They [inaudible] or [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] totals toasted.
It was just a possibility that he could,
okay.
[inaudible] it cannot show UNT Paul
[inaudible] [inaudible] you cannot think of Miro
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] Portola Persona,
but in total opposite [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] Mundo DNA [inaudible] gives us,
they should be done under Resto [inaudible] case I lost that.
Can Not put that in a mobile.
Miranda was one of our mass meme culture.
Miranda [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] persona.
So if a dentist without [inaudible] and [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] that
is in [inaudible] noise.
Lse Toys is get the media analysis.
[inaudible] the Kiddo.
Okay.
Then whichever 10 o'clock here.
Take one thing.
Contigo.
[inaudible] a solicitor.
Can I address it to key?
No.
A uterus.
You to look at the [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] in [inaudible] and Manos.
How mass
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] in Eh,
eh.
Formentera the wound.
Barco he means say I'm
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] right,
but
they're not commerce any,
they're behind in labor.
They don't Hispaniola so [inaudible] no,
no.
[inaudible] Riva.
You know how to and when?
Not Familiar.
It could be to say
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] that machine
[inaudible] [inaudible] the stuff that goes into [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] you so when the nurse will not be tough for
us.
Media.
Voila,
mayor.
I lost personas,
personas,
personas.
Come near those.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] I want the political molecule.
[inaudible] [inaudible] or
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] to or tourists.
Tourists done this.
Hello?
Paul Giamatti goes,
oh no.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] as he nursed inadequate
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] you've been at least the Middle Ages.
They don't,
they don't.
[inaudible] Triplett two different thing.
Winner so that it does.
No [inaudible] minutes.
Personas.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] in the military too,
but not as bad about safety or Tokay personas.
Camilo get Jeff and Daniel [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] Pero in system Joe [inaudible].
You think of this?
[inaudible] [inaudible] bow traffic,
aunties mallows [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] he said
then with Yammer,
Charles Traffic,
aunties [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] it was windows.
Those windows Solos Carolina in [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] Los
[inaudible] are liberals.
I was doing something and start to us.
Hello
[inaudible] [inaudible] models one master prop your meals.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] but still,
she simply nothing.
[inaudible] done.
The ICM Broomfield Alpha leaf pocket of personas.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] no.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] is to get on.
Did you get a mellow?
You don't want to list
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] to set one up
persona.
[inaudible] [inaudible] you get finished
very muchi.
Zimmer's [inaudible] has no,
yeah.
Can we talk about
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
I see.
Okay.
I lost no,
I again,
yeah,
but he's good
dose
looking on his Facebook.
Oh No.
Did he thought,
cause we were
the
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] no.
Lucky.
Yes.
Get after.
And I got off.
Yes,
he could have.
Yes.
[inaudible] [inaudible] the career major,
the Credit Mila Chassis.
Decker Schumer.
Your support.
[inaudible] but [inaudible]
[inaudible].